[Music]
I did studies which did
not predestine me to work in the
European institutions but I had
friends who worked and they
made me want to take competitive exams
after several years as an
independent and  in a profession that is a bit
dangerous for a person
not seeing it because my eyesight is diminishing, I was lucky enough
to come across by chance which brought me
to the European Commission
Street
institution
I have always been interested in
questions linked to  diversity and
inclusion and they have become
central in
European institutions we can talk about them without
fear of being stigmatized
alongside my work at the
European Commission I created I
chair the Haiti public utility foundation
which supports people
visually impaired people of their
life course in the idea that the
visual handicap does not prevent you from having a
life like everyone else
politics
it is a multicultural environment
open to diversity we are all
different also to you person in a
situation of  disability I can only
invite you to register to take
competitive examinations here at the
European Commission all adaptations
according to your specificities are
planned
[Music]